Bom dia, Rafa.
Bom dia.
Cedo ainda, né?
[Música]
தன
சна
[Música]
tiang
budang
saran
கசமி
[Música]
சரணி
สัง
சமி
[Música]
ตி
புத
சன
[Música]
சமி
สังмова
[Música]
அரஹம
சбу
[Música]
지수라
지나
[Música]
Grup
honra
grup.
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Hra
guru
honra
gur
[Música]
Grup
honra
grup.
Grup
honra
grup.
[Música]
Hal
grup
honra
Grup
gur
honom.
Honrazar
gur
honra romanzar.
[Música]
Honra
grup.
[Música]
Hara
grup
honra
Grup
Hraz
[Música]
honom
grára.
[Música]
Hraz
honom.
[Música]
Агатера
சஹ
Paraga,
[Música]
So
[Aplausos]
[Música]
G
para
[Música]
sanga
de sate
[Música]
[Risadas]
Tempar
sang
[Música]
de novo. Bom dia.
Bom dia.
>> Acho super lindo a tua voz,
não é, bonita?
Super linda.
E ela pegou o jeito. Não, ela pegou o
jeito.
Cheiro bonito.
Mas a voz dela, eu acho que tenta até
fazer um pouco mais grave, mas não tem
como né?
É bonito assim, porque dá um contraste,
né? O grave com agudo fica bonito.
Errado né?
Bom, se a Sara tanto fácil.
Mas então, não sei se vocês têm alguma
gente tá se encontrando agora, terminou,
né? Não sei o que que vai acontecer
daqui paraa frente também. A gente vai
se despedir logo em seguida, né? Então,
não sei se vocês têm algum alguma coisa
que vocês aspiram especialmente, né?
enquanto a conversa de hoje, né?
Então põe o chimarrão aí porque agora
começa
>> elaborando
que tirar uma fotografia do gaúcho aqui
em Paris. Eu acho.
>> É verdade. Aí pega os dois.
A deixa
>> é uma praticante. Licença.
>> Eles estão se exibindo aí pro chimarrão.
Ah,
obrigado. Obrigado.
Esse chimarrão tá bom.
Super bom.
Então,
>> sim,
eu amo mais.
>> Tem gente online,
>> tem.
Ó,
cinco.
1 2 3 4 5.
Mas aí, ó, Barcelona entrou.
>> Tô tentando
lá em casa. A grande
confundar um CEB, um CTG e uma um
consulado do Grêmio.
A legal
corpo morto
é inclusive o DNA
E tem uma
alta,
>> tem uma energia sutil que vem do grande
do grande vazio, não do silêncio.
Cuidado.
Então essa vacuidade
ela ela tem uma vontade de
de se associar com a elemento terra, com
a matéria
que a gente tá aqui. Tem um outro ali.
>> É essa essa energia, ela não vê a
matéria.
A gente vê a matéria, né? Mas eh é como
se nesse nível sutil não tivesse
propriamente matéria, tem movimento de
energia, tem luminosidade.
Mas quando nós estamos olhando de um
jeito operativo, então a gente vê isso,
né? Mas vamos supor os cientistas
olhando essa mesa aí eles botam o
microscópio, aí ele começa a sumir a
mesa né?
Então tem um nível que tu vem assim, aí
tu vê a mesa, mas se tu entrar num outro
nível, tu já não vê a mesa, tu começa a
ver fibras. Tu entrar num outro nível,
tu vai olhando as substâncias, né? Mas
se tu entrar num outro nível, tu vai ver
as energias circulando.
Esse é o ponto.
Então o o aspecto da energia é o aspecto
mais.
Aí tuos outros aspectos são delusivos,
são
construções delusivas etapa por etapa
assim,
>> mas tu pode perceber aquilo. Vamos
supor, tem uma mente tipo nermanakaia
que entra num dos mundos delusivos,
começa a operar da forma como aqueles
seres operam, passa a ver daquele modo
também. Por exemplo, nós temos a
possibilidade de, em vez de olhar as
peças do jogo, a gente vê o jogo, a
gente tem essa possibilidade, mas o jogo
é um aspecto delusivo por cima das
peças. Aí eu posso ver as peças, mas eu
posso começar a ver a matéria dentro das
peças, eu posso começar a ver energia
dentro da matéria dentro das peças. Mas
são níveis de realidade, sendo que o
nível mais eh mais profundo é justamente
a grande vacuidade e o movimento
luminoso
que
produz o movimento da energia.
O,
>> eu tenho um agente, tem uma, tem um ser
em algum momento, né, que produz o
movimento da energia ou produz o
movimento da luminosidade da mente
numa certa direção e não em outra, por
exemplo.
ter chocado que não nada.
Por que que isso já
se essa não é a pergunta dele, pode ser
a tua. Então,
começar,
>> é, professor, é,
é, tá, essa é a pergunta dela. Então, eu
respondo pergunta de onde surge a
vacuidade. É que esse é um ponto assim,
né? Nós estamos com a mente do jogo. A
mente do jogo, ela tá ela tá olhando
coisas que surgem e movimentos e
aparências variadas. Então essa mente
ela ela tá operando com coisas que surge
excesso, surge excesso. Mas a vacuidade
a gente não consegue vê ela, vamos
dizer, esse grande essa grande essa
grande abertura, ela não tem um instante
que ela não esteja lá.
E a grande abertura ela não muda.
Portanto, dentro da grande abertura tu
não encontra tempo,
não encontra uma evolução temporal da
grande abertura. Então aquilo não tem
muito sentido, mas os mundos criados
eles surgem e tem uma um encadeamento e
tem uma realidade ali dentro. É como,
por exemplo, o tempo do jogo só começa
depois que o jogo começa. Então não tem
aquele tempo. Aquele tempo é o tempo
criado. Então os tempos estão criados
junto com as coisas que são criadas.
É uma coisa meio esquisita assim, mas a
gente também pode perguntar como é que
surge o tempo do jogo, como é que surge
a urgência do tempo do jogo?
E é assim, aquele tempo, ele é um
aspecto delusivo que também passa a
existir como um intervalo entre as
diferentes jogadas, entre como o espaço
aonde aquele tipo de pensamento tá
ocorrendo,
mas o tempo de fato a gente não vai
encontrar uma substancialidade para ele,
né?
Então esse é um ponto bem interessante.
Na física quântica, na álgebra de
projetores, não aparece o tempo.
Sei lá na o jogo, a boliana aí como é
que fica, mas eu acho que não tem tempo
também.
Ah, o tempo ele é introduzido
artificialmente por uma análise
estatística.
Por exemplo, tem estados,
mas quando ah o sistema tá num estado,
tu não tem por sair daquele estado. Ele
tá num estado,
vou dizer dentro da algores, na física
quântica, tu não tem assim, ele tá
dentro de um estado e tá gastando tempo
que ele pode ficar dentro do estado,
então ele sai do estado. Não, não tem.
Ele pode simplesmente permanecer no
estado. Estado é alguma coisa que não
tem tempo dentro.
E espantosamente,
horrivelmente, perturbadoramente também
não tem localização.
Localização espacial. Onde dizer o
estado quântico ele tá aonde? Aí tu não
encontra um lugar físico para ele.
Isso é muito perturbador. Não é como é
que eu vou dizer? não é analisado dentro
desse do sistema, porque do mesmo modo
quando tu tá jogando um jogo, tu não
fica pensando como é que o tá se
sentindo aí sozinho na frente. Isso já é
uma coisa que não faz sentido, né? Então
dentro do jogo, tu pensa o que o jogo
pensa, mas vamos dizer quando tu olha de
uma distância, de uma outra distância e
começa a comparar
visões de diferentes lugares, né? aquilo
é um pouco estranho. Então, existe, por
exemplo, os efeitos não locais da física
quântica, né, que é muito perturbador.
Por exemplo, uma um um elétron que é
jogado contra uma chapa metálica, o que
que vai acontecer com ele? Não, não
depende do do que que onde é que ele tá
entrando.
Porque quando ele entra, ele não tá se
relacionando com a matéria da chapa, ele
tá se relacionando com os estados
quânticos que estão ali.
E os estados quânticos que estão ali,
eles são representados pelo conjunto de
átomos que estão dentro da chapa, que
criam os estados quânticos. Se os se os
estados quânticos estão preenchidos
naquele elétron que entra ali, ele não
interage, ele não é preso, ele
atravessa.
Se houver, por exemplo, estados
quânticos que tão
que estão em níveis de energia
disponíveis, semelhantes ao a energia do
elétron que tá entrando, ele pode ser
capturado e o excesso de energia ele
emite como luz, pum, ou como calor, ele
fica preso. Então nós, a chapa absorveu
aquela partícula. Mas como é que é
decidido isso? Isso não é decidido pelo
lugar como a gente pensa que vai dar
tiros pá pá. aquela balanquele lugar,
não é decidido, decidido pelos estados
quânticos. E aquilo é como se houvesse
um universo paralelo onde as coisas são
decididas, elas não são decididas ali
naquela matéria.
Aí tem outros efeitos que são não
locais, por exemplo,
que é o, por exemplo, as a dupla fenda,
a experiência da dupla fenda que é muito
perturbadora também.
Ela ali não, não tem como negar.
Não vou contar
em vista da do clamor popular.
>> Eu aprendi aqui a coisa assim.
[Risadas]
Não, o que acontece é assim, ó. Vocês,
isso é uma experiência de laboratória de
física, uma coisa comum. Você pode pegar
uma uma chapa, um uma cartolina, fazer
um furo nela, passa a luz pelo furo. Uma
cartolina preta passa a luz.
Aí se aquele furo for pequeno,
a a a as ondas luminosas quando passam
por ali, elas produzem uma franja de
interferência que pode ser fotografada
com anéis concêntrico
numa chapa fotográfica que tu coloca
atrás. Então tá tudo uma câmera escura e
emite aquela luz. tem eh tem esses anéis
concêntricos que surgem em volta desse
simetricamente em volta do furo. Bem,
isso todo mundo já viu isso
como uma onda que e eh
é isso, viu? Você não não fez a aula de
física,
tu lembra? Então,
e você passou como?
a pergunta. É,
desculpa.
É, ele vai tratar disso. Não, ele vai
tratar disso, né? É, mas aí
aí tu emite um fóton por fóton,
aí tu tem uma sensação de que fóton é
como se fosse um partícula de luz.
Eh, aí tu emite aquilo, ele passa
certinho pelo furo e atinge a chapa
fotográfica do do lado de lá. Aí tu
emite um, outro, outro e aquilo produz
uma franja, produz um os círculos
concêntrico.
Mas se tu tiver dois furos,
aí emite o fóton, o fóton aí eu já não
sei para onde que eu vou.
Aí o fóton a gente pensa, ele passa por
um lado ou passa pelo outro.
Mas aí o que que vai acontecer? O fóton
ele,
então a gente imaginaria, ele passa por
um lado ou passa pelo outro, então vai
dar uma mancha de um lado e uma mancha
do outro lado igual ao que era antes.
Se eu tiver só um furo, eu tapo o furo
de novo. Aí dá só uma mancha. Tapo o
outro furo, dá só uma mancha. Mas aí eu
deixo os dois furos, não dá duas
manchas,
dá uma franja de interferência.
Eh, ou seja, o fóton passa pelos dois
lados e interfere com ele mesmo e produz
uma franja de interferência.
Aí tu diz: "Bom, é evidente que é uma
onda, não é uma partícula".
Por isso ele passa pelos dois lados,
interfere e produz aquilo.
Mas aí vem o efeito fotoelétrico.
Isso tem uma eh iso tem um um material,
quando ele é atingido pela luz,
ele começa a passar elétrons, libera
elétrons, ou seja, a luz bate nos
elétrons que estão, libera esses
elétrons e os elétrons correm e produz
uma passagem de eletricidade
num num material.
Aí tu faz o cálculo, não tem como a luz
chegar em tudo aquilo
e arrancar elétrons,
porque ela se espalha por todo lugar.
Então ela tem que chegar num elétron
específico, pim. Aí aquele eletron eh se
libera. Então aí tu diz: "Não, a luz é
um corpúsculo, é um fóton". Então daí
que vem a teoria corpuscular,
corpúsculo, teoria corpuscular da luz
que deu ao Einstein o prêmio Nobel.
Aí o Einstein, ele foi o primeiro que
viu a luz como composto de partículas
luminosas, no caso fótons,
né? Aí a gente volta pra experiência de
dupla fenda. Aí estão os fótons que a
gente sabe que é fótons que é uma
partícula, mas aí eles têm dois furos,
eles passam pelos dois furos. Então tu
não consegue dizer que ele é fóton, que
ele é uma partícula ou é uma onda.
Então isso é o paradoxo da dualidade
onda partícula.
Aí tu tem num experimento, tu prova que
é onda, no outro experimento tu prova
que é prática.
para gravar as coisas, tu descobre que o
fóton tem massa.
Aí tu olha pra luz, a luz, essa luz aí,
essa luz é afetada gravitacionalmente.
Os corpos de grande massa fazem com que
a luz se curve. Por isso quando é
>> isso.
Essa parte tu essa parte tu estudou.
Aí tem isso aí. Eles viram, foi aqui no
Brasil, a primeira vez que eles viram
isso, que aí a lua tava tapando
uma estrela num eclipse. Essa estrela
não podia ser vista, mas ela foi vista.
É,
>> porque a luz fez uma curva em volta do
sol
e os cientistas não podiam ver aquela
estrela, mas viram a estrela. Então
aquilo tava aprovado. Eles montaram
tudo. Foi lá no acho que foi Crato no
Ceará. Crato.
>> Pode ser que seja Sobrão.
>> Eu acho que foi Sobral.
>> É. Aí foi lá, eles montaram, veio o
cientista de todo mundo, vieram porque
eles estavam esperando aquele eclipse
para ver isso, né? Aí, é, aquilo aquilo
ficou ficou ruim, ficou chato, porque a
onda tem agora eh tem peso, ela é
afetada gravitacionalmente.
Então, isso estava previsto pelo I na
na teoria corpular da luz, que ele ele
vê a energia do a energia do daquele
fóton e ele converte a energia daquele
fóton em massa. Por quê? Porque energia
é MC2.
E igual a MC2. Então toda energia tá
associada a ela uma massa.
Coisa é
esse ponto. Então surge esse essa
questão. Então também tem as questões de
tonelamento que teus amigos devem ter
contado também. Ou seja, um um elétron,
ele tá num lugar para passar para outro
material, ele precisaria subir, ele
precisa ter muita energia para poder
atravessar aquele aquela barreira de
energia. Aí ele ele faz tunelamento, ele
atravessa por baixo que ninguém saiba
como aparece do outro lado
com a mesma cara,
como se nada tivesse acontecido. Então
esse atravessa,
>> ele atravessa. É como por exemplo, vamos
supor que tu tem um, esse é o exemplo
que se dá na fía, vem com um carrinho ou
com, vamos supor, um skate um no plano,
aí tem uma lomba,
se tu não tiver energia para subir com a
lomba, para descer do outro lado, tu não
sobe. Tu entra na lomba e para. Mas aí o
skatitista tem habilidade de
tonelamento,
aí ele se concentra. Ah, passa por
baixo, chega do outro lado.
Uma coisa simples.
É o tunela, não. Tá cheio de dessas
coisas. Aí os cientistas viram isso,
criaram os diodos de tonelamento,
criaram eh
eh componentes eletrônicos que fazem
esse efeito de tonelamento, né, que pode
ser utilizado em circuito eletrônico.
A eletrônica toda, ela tá baseada na
física quântica.
Meio aquilo bem mais interessante assim.
>> Engenheira.
Aham.
de repente vocês já eram vidas passadas
e eu nunca tinha muito cansado nessa
possibilidade porque assim quando eu
comecei, né, agora esses meos ajudar f
nossa, eu tô então no início do caminho,
não sei quanto tempo
>> pouquinho mais perto,
>> não sei quanto tempo ainda vai durar. E
aí foi a primeira vez que eu tive essa
perspectiva. De repente eu já estava no
caminho, só que eu não tenho
consciência. Eu não sei se tem como ter
consciência, se a gente está começando,
se a gente tá no meio, a gente, enfim, é
um pouco que eu pergunta. Tem como sa
>> Essa é uma pergunta. Ah, é evidente que
tu já tava no caminho.
É obras,
>> não. Porque é assim, se tu entende
alguma coisa, por exemplo, eu tô aqui
falando em língua portuguesa, aí tu
entende é evidente que tu sabe
português. Aí eu tô aqui falando o
budismo, tu entende? É
essencial. É claro que tu tem os
receptores para entender,
senão não tem como entender. Tem como
>> tem como saber
>> o que que aconteceu?
se situar no cab ou ou é por exemplo, se
eu morri,
eu esqueço tudo, porque eu entendi que
sem esse conceito de acumular mérites
nas suas vidas passadas, isso vai
passando, né, pro pro futuro. Você não
perde isso. Mas eu não sei se tem como
saber.
>> É,
>> o sistema de pontos, né?
E nem que tem o
>> esgotou os pontos.
Os pontos estavam quase respirando.
Tem que usar nos próximos três dias.
Mas no mínimo, por exemplo, é fácil de
dizer. Aí os mestin dizem: "Olha, é
assim, você tem seguido o caminho, mas
você tem muitas ideias próprias.
Então veja, as ideias próprias que você
tinha na vida passada não foram até o
final, não deu certo até o final. para
melhor você ouvir com cuidado
e seguir da melhor forma, né? É assim, a
gente é, eu tenho, eu sou tenho uma
tendência a ter ideias próprias, de
fazer as coisas temosamente.
Isso sempre dá certo. A gente pode falar
assim, qualquer um é algumas pessoas,
porque essa é a nossa característica.
Mas aquilo não tem. Às vezes as pessoas
lembram: "Ah, porque não, eu sinto que
isso, eu sinto que aquilo, eu sinto
isso, sinto aquilo." A pessoa também
pode dizer: "Olha, você tem sentido
muita, muitas coisas vidas após vida e
não tem dado certo, então é melhor ficar
atento." Mas esse ponto,
[Música]
também não tem um tempo dentro disso,
né? não tem um tempo, porque
essencialmente a gente pode dizer que
uma mente livre acessou uma região de
sabedoria. Então ela tem receptores para
aquilo, porque aquele som vem e aqueles
significados aparecem, porque os
significados não tão no som. Então eu tô
só emitindo sons aqui. Se aí surgem
significados, é porque os significados
eles estão ali, né? Eles podem ser
sentido, né? Eu mereço. Eu acho que o
Buda tem uma habilidade de falar pros
seres que tão que tem algum nível de
sofrimento.
Então ele vai começar desse modo porque
todo mundo tem conexão com um nível de
frustração e sofrimento. Então ele fala
desde esse ponto, aquilo dá certo, todo
mundo pensa, pá, isso faz sentido, né?
Mas aqui nós estamos falando uma coisa
bem complicada,
bem complicada, ligada ao reconhecimento
da realidade, né? A gente tá até nem tá
falando de sofrimento.
A gente tá falando da essência do
sofrimento enquanto a as visões que se
que se ficam limitadas, né? E isso não é
uma coisa que as pessoas entendam
rapidamente enfim.
Elas, em primeiro lugar, elas nem
consideram isso relevante.
Thiago depochia ficava um pouco admirado
assim, né? Porque ele chegou no Brasil,
ele ia dar uma palestra, aparecer 500
pessoas,
eles ficavam: "Uau, como que essas
pessoas elas têm conexão?" Então ele
achava que ele, enfim, tinha encontrar
em outras vidas daquelas pessoas, porque
senão aquilo não aconteceria.
Aí uma vez eu vi esse relato, eu não
ouvi isso dele, mas eu vi esse relato
que ele tinha dito que quando ele teve
preso uma época pelo rei Trisundut, pelo
rei
Langarmas, ele tinha, ele morreu na
prisão, então ele fez muitas práticas
aspirando dar benefício pros seres em
outras vidas. Ele acreditava que tava
acontecendo isso.
Aí ele teve essa intuição de vir pro
Brasil, né, fazer isso. Foi certeiro.
Assim, ele pulou no abismo e foi
certeiro né?
Incrível.
Pois é. Mais alguma pergunta?
>> Eu tenho uma pergunta,
>> por favor.
pensando a person che pratican o
buddismo al mismo tempo che praticano
un'altra religião per un catolicismo.
Existe tipo de casos
>> e como é que funciona? Faz sentido?
Funciona?
>> É que esse é um ponto tão interessante,
sabe? Eu vi, teve o quantos portugueses
apareceram lá pelo pelo Japão, aí eles
trouxeram o catolicismo, né?
E
aquilo eles eles respeitavam outras
tradições, achavam que as várias
tradições enriqueciam.
Então eles viram: "Uau, que tem um tem
uma realidade". Isso é muito
interessante, porque esses povos, esses
brancos com essas caravelas estão
chegando aqui, eles estão trazendo uma
outra espiritualidade. Isso é muito
interessante. Isso vai enriquecer a
nossa visão. A gente quer aprender
disso, né? Então essa foi a primeira
abordagem dos japoneses. Então eles
acolheram
mensagem do mensagem
como interpreta. Eh, parece que tem
muita ligação, porque afinal é o amor,
né? É o amor, a palavra do amor. Então,
parece que são umas conexões.
>> Mas aí o que aconteceu? Os portugueses,
eu tenho, tô cheio de amigos portugueses
também,
os portugueses, eles chegaram lá, mas
eles estavam dentro de um processo
eh global de dominação.
Aquilo tinha o papa por trás e tinha o
rei de Portugal e tinha o domínio sobre
as rotas eh comerciais e tinha uma
dominação política e militar que eles
aspiravam. E teve um momento que os
japoneses se deram conta.
Eles se deram conta. Aí eles começaram a
perseguir,
mas o eles expulsaram todos os padres,
expulsaram todas as expressões
religiosas portuguesas e católicas,
mandaram todo mundo embora. que o
catolicismo tinha penetrado na sociedade
na sociedade japonesa.
E eles não conseguiam extirpar isso.
Sempre apareciam os padres,
chegavam de barco, entravam na praia, se
escondiam, as pessoas escondiam eles e
começou a ver uma subversão católica
dentro do Japão.
E aí viu uma repressão do Estado, né?
uma repressão forte, detalhada assim,
mas eles nunca conseguiam efetivamente
extirpar. Aí surgiu um chogum muito
inteligente que levou aquilo ao final.
Então ele ele ele era um um budista,
né? Porque a tradição era budista. Aí
ele olhou aquilo, ele viu, não, eles não
viraram católicos.
Eles agora têm uma roupagem para a
espiritualidade deles, uma outra
roupagem para a espiritualidade deles.
Então esse é um ponto que eu acho muito
interessante, que é como eu responderia
isso. Então a gente tem como que uma
espiritualidade,
essa espiritualidade
quando uma tradição surge, ela não chega
a alterar a espiritualidade. A gente
diz: "Não, isso eu pensava, isso eu
vejo, isso eu sinto."
Então, nós temos um movimento interno
que vai ficando eh que ele é nutrido
pelas pelas diferentes espiritualidades.
Então, é natural que as pessoas durante
um tempo elas
ouçam de diferentes lugares e aquilo e
aquilo ressoa, aquilo faz sentido pra
pessoa,
mas aquilo tá nutrindo uma intuição que
a pessoa tem e tá nutrindo as
experiências dessa vida, de outras
vidas. E as conexões estão aparecendo,
né? Então eles viram isso, esse jogum
ele viu isso, né? E aí ele conseguiu,
tem um, tem um filme disso que chama O
Silêncio e tem um livro também que é O
Silêncio. Essa expressão, eu nunca vi a
expressão silêncio ser assustadora, mas
vocês vão ver essa expressão silêncio
ser assustador,
porque eles começaram a torturar os
praticantes católicos
e diziam: "Agora reze para Deus".
E Deus ficou em silêncio.
Então ele o eles venceram os católicos
pelo silêncio de Deus. Aquilo foi
horrível. E eles venceram os padres pelo
silêncio de Deus. Mas eles não
torturavam os padres.
Eles diziam: "Olha lá o vocês criaram
esses fiéis todos. Olha o que que eles
estão passando agora.
Nós não vamos deixar isso progredir.
Agora veja, reze para Deus para isso
parar. Botava os padres a rezar para
Deus e aquilo não parava.
Aí eles diziam: "Então agora vocês
abandonem a fé de você
e aí eu libero eles." Aí os padres
apostatavam, que é o verbo que se usa
para isso, se tornavam apóstatas. Ou
seja, rejeitava a fé cristã.
Horrível,
assustador assim, mas tem esse livro,
tem esse esse esse relato, né? Mas
quando os portugueses foram recebidos
lá, eles foram super bem recebidos.
Vocês vão ver, por exemplo, na arte
japonesa, a representação das caravelas,
das roupas deles chegando, os cachorros.
Tu vê assim a corte portuguesa, a forma
portuguesa, forma europeia de se
manifestar assim. E os e os japoneses
começaram a adotar as roupas
portuguesas, adotar os modos
portugueses, foram adotando. Eles
acharam aquilo interessante.
Aí num certo momento, eles se
assustaram.
É tem
>> o casal Fábio Bento, que é casado com
uma italiana nascida em Roma. Eles
moraram em anos. Então, é um,
>> ele é um teólogo
>> ele é um teólogo católico, estudou em
Roma e a esposa dele estudou também em
Roma, estudou no Vaticano, ela é uma
especialista em em relações
internacionais do Vaticano.
E eles eles são praticantes budistas
também.
>> É o próprio Papa também. Não é o papa
não, mas é que a gente tá esperando. Não
deu tempo. Mas eu tava querendo lá o
Francisco, mas não deu tempo.
Isso é bobagem. Estão aqui me brincando.
Tô brincando. Mas a gente brinca porque
o Francisco era gaúcho também. Gaúcho da
Argentina. Tomava chimarrão também.
Coloricismo. Existem algumas contradões
assim? Não sei se tem alguma muito
grande ou se
>> tem algumas, mas todas elas se resolvem.
Por exemplo, vocês vão encontrar eh
teólogos, tem tem textos de teólogos
mostrando como que o catolicismo pegou
várias ideias e várias representações
budistas, porque o budismo veio antes,
né?
E a e a tradição católica, ela não
começou com Cristo.
Tem esse problema também. Ela vai
começar muito depois com Paulo e ela é
patrocinada, tem um enrosco político
também,
o imperador
que ele então ele consegue algumas
vantagens se impondo uma nova fé
e perseguindo os outros que seguiam as
outras coisas. Então tem essas coisas
assim.
E aí quando o catolicismo surge, ele
surge já com uma religião de estado.
Ele primeiro ele tá, ele é perseguido,
depois ele ele ganha esse foro, essa
grande expansão.
Então essa grande expansão nem veio por
Paulo, ela vem num tempo posterior
assim.
para espiritualidade
que quer botar uma uma Maria Buda no
altar um
né?
a gente vai sempre encontrar muito essas
semelhanças, porque de fato quando
qualquer tradição ela vai se refinando,
ela vai indo em direção a à simplicidade
original.
Aí é o ponto culminante e vai
convergindo.
Então, só santidade da da leilama, ele
enfatizava a unidade das tradições
religiosas, a abordagem mahiana também.
Por exemplo, o movimento rim trata da
unidade das tradições budistas. E essa
visão marra, ela trata da eh da unidade
das múltiplas tradições religiosas.
Palail deu vários ensinamentos sobre
isso, especificamente assim. Eu lembro
que às vezes as pessoas contestavam o
próprio da Leilamban, Manan, porque ele
falava num âmbito muito informal e as
pessoas tinham uma possibilidade de
intervir assim. E eu lembro, nós
publicamos um desses textos que era
Diálogos de Bodigaia pelo pelo Cabezon,
que foi o tradutor.
E a gente publicou esse texto pela
editora Paranita acho que na década de
80 ainda.
Isso eu acho que até a gente deveria
republicar
diálogos de Budigia. É muito
interessante aquele livro da Leila, né?
E eh aí ele
eh o da lei lama contestado, né?
Ele aí vem um praticante e diz: "Mas
como é que nós vamos considerar que
essas tradições que não falam iluminação
elas possam ser semelhantes ao budismo
que, enfim, descreve coisas sutisas?"
Sim,
ele vou dar uma resposta que eu achei
muito interessante. Ele diz que ah,
o caminho espiritual ele não é para
cumprir uma vida, a gente leva muitas
vidas. Então, é natural que a gente
também siga por algum caminho e mais
adiante esses caminhos se juntam com
outros e que levam, enfim, até o ponto
final.
[Música]
É é.
Então esse é um ponto interessante
assim porque
o argumento geral disso é assim, quando
nós falamos de Deus, é como se tivesse
falando do sol. Aqui nós estamos aqui, a
gente olha pro sol, mas quando a gente
vê o sol, nós vemos o sol com olhos
humanos.
A gente não consegue ver o sol no como
uma estrela dentro de uma galáxia.
A gente olha, a gente diz: "Ah, o sol se
levanta leste, por oeste". Esse é o
nosso olhar, né? Então, por Deus é uma
res parecida. Se eu tenho esse olhar
humano, eu vejo desse modo, né? Então,
eu posso criticar o próprio olhar que me
permite ver a Deus. Então, eu vejo, eu
falo sobre Deus, mas eu não vejo de
fato. Esse é o
E isso de algum modo eh ressoa dentro da
própria tradição católica, porque na
tradição católica vai se dizer que a
gente não deveria usar os o santo nome
de Deus em vão.
É como se houvesse uma dificuldade de
nós vermos de fato, né? Então a gente
pode olhar, eu muitas vezes digo, bom,
as pessoas rezam para Deus como quem
reza para Mara e Mara responde como se
fosse Deus. Então esse é um ponto
delicado, assim, por exemplo, tu reza
para
o filho passar no vestibular, por
exemplo né?
A Mara, que é o senhor da ilusão, sem
ele concede. Mas isso não é um assunto
para Deus.
Então nós vamos encontrar, por exemplo,
os cruzados invadindo a Rússia para
destruir os ortodoxos.
Aí Deus é o mesmo, mesmíssimo Deus.
E aí como é que fica, né? Aí, por
exemplo, os cruzados sendo atacados e
atacando os islâmicos.
Mas todos eles pertencem à mesma
tradição abraâmica.
O Deus é o mesmo.
E aí todos eles Senhor, eu sigo a sua
vontade. O outro lado Senhor, eu sigo a
sua vontade, me conceda a vitória. E aí
eles
e aí
eu acho que eles ficam que parar um
pouco e pensar
sobre isso, né? Como é que se Deus tá
querendo que um se mate, eles se matem
ou se ou ou se relacionem melhor assim,
né? Esse problema que como a gente viu,
não terminou, né?
Continua. Deus é o mesmo e as pessoas
são, as pessoas estão se matando aqui a
Europa inteira.
Europa inteira. Nós estamos sobre o
mesmo Deus. E aqui as pessoas vão se
matando o tempo todo.
Então que Deus é esse Deus que as
pessoas pensam que tão vendo
e fazem tudo do jeito que fazem, né?
Mas essa crítica, ela não é uma crítica
fora do catolicismo. Catolicismo tem os
os pensadores, os teólogos que vem isso
também né?
Os teólogos são muito inteligentes.
O a inteligência de Roma é muito grande.
Eles viram muitas diferentes culturas.
Eles olharam aquilo, foram desafiados
por muitas diferentes religiões e
culturas. Então aquilo tá tudo vivo
dentro do Vaticano e do estado do
Vaticano. Eles têm uma inteligência
assim sobre aquilo.
Tem um Deus que tá fora
Deus.
E essa natureza de Buda é uma natureza
que que tá em cada ser vivo. A gente só
não reconhece ela,
né? Mas essa é
ã mas isso é cada ser manifesta essa
natureza de Buda o tempo todo, né? que é
essa luminosidade que nos permite
criar os nossos mundos, criar as nossas
bolhas, criar as nossas identidades.
Então o budismo é como se a gente
andasse no sentido de reconhecer
essa natureza que já tá presente em cada
sertivo, não só nos humanos, mas em cada
ser.
>> Esse é um ponto interessante, sabe? Eu
acho que Cristo ele tinha uma visão mais
budista do que a religião católica lá
depois estabeleceu, né? Porque, por
exemplo, ah, Cristo ele ele trouxe uma
visão universal paraa religião e não uma
visão de um povo, né? Então ele fez essa
grande transição que a gente pode não
entender bem, mas a religião, vamos
dizer, o Antigo Testamento é a religião
de um povo, a religião do povo judaico
que entregava os os outros povos para
eles nas batalhas. Era assim como havia
naquela época. Todo mundo rezava pro
outro pelo Deus, né? Então, Jeová era
isso.
Mas Deus vai mudando, né?
Então, o Deus de Cristo já é um Deus que
salva todos. Ele não salva apenas os
judeus, ele salva todos. Então, o
cristianismo se torna uma religião
universal
assim. Então, isso é alguma coisa muito
especial assim, né?
Seria um muda, seria iluminante?
>> Dalilama diz da leilama diz que o que
Cristo era um muda.
>> É.
É é não
é porque ele passa um tempo,
tem a infância, depois tem o retorno
dele. Então, nesse período, eles dizem
que ele andou por lá.
É, eleou eu fiquei casando na lateral,
foi na visão retórica, essa resistência,
eu acho.
Ah uma
>> é pecado,
>> é do diabo, na verdade. Já perguntei
para um padre, gosto assim, eu tenho tem
uma ligação também da minha mãe, enfim,
e na missa e tal. E um dia eu perguntei,
né, porque minha mãe não batizou no
catolicismo.
E aí um dia eu perguntei, né, pro padre,
falei: "Olha, padre, eu eh até, né, já
pensei em me batizar, mas eu gosto de
meditar, eu gosto do budismo, comecei
assim, conversar com ele, né?" E aí eu
falei, como é que a visão, né, católica
sobre isso? Porque eu não vejo, tipo,
abrindo mão, né, disso assim. Daí ele
falou assim, não, quando você se batiza,
você entra, você o céu se abre para você
e você se compromete a amar Jesus e a
igreja o bem a verdade e alguma outra
coisa que a gente falou também. E todas
as outras eh são, ele não falou isso,
né? Mas ele falou assim, a única verdade
é Jesus Cristo. É assim, é Jesus Cristo
que ele ensinou através da Bíblia. E mas
depois eu, enfim, a visão deles é que
todos os outras, né, espalmente
politeístas, porque o caso do budismo,
ele não é politeísta, né, mas eu falei
porque fui batizada no yoga e tal, aí
ele falou, não, eh, não, a visão é que
são eh manifestações diabólicas mesmo,
assim,
na visão deles, né,
que tem mais tradonis, eu falei com
tradon
da do da geração de hoje estaria de
forma diferente. Então tudo ele não
poderia antes,
>> mas a doutrina
é muito importante.
>> É porque só uma verdade, eles são mono,
então eles acreditam que só existe uma
possibilidade de verdade para seguir
Jesus Cristo. Tudo que pode esse corpo
para eles é a ilusão que o diabo cria,
né? Porque eles têm essa noção do diabo
e de Deus. Deus seria isso, que Jesus é
a única manifestação de Deus na terra
>> que existiu e tal, pelo nosso pecado. E
o diabo é o esse esse anjo caído, já sei
lá, eu não entendo tanto, mas é isso.
Eles tem essa essa ideia, entendeu? Tudo
que não é Jesus e a verdade que tá na
Bíblia seria manifão.
Como é que eu acredito que eu acredito
que posso ter diferente?
enfim não me considero mais católica,
mas que eu tenha feito batizado
catecismo e, enfim, não segui muito, mas
a gente viu mesmo agora fazendo um filme
tem muitas tem, né, a vamos dizer os
padres que são mais conservadores,
outros que são mais abertos. Então eu
imagino
>> que dentro mesmo da igreja vão ter
pessoas, digamos com essa visão assim
bem é isso e é isso essa doutrina e
outros que
>> podem mais flexíveis. Eu acredito, mas
não não tem como. Desculpemar porque
não tem aí eu acho difícil, né? Quando a
única verdade era dela,
>> aí eu vejo que é justamente isso produz
a guerra, né? Porque eu tenho que
eliminar o outro, porque se a minha
única verdade é verdadeira. Então aí eu
acho que entra muito em todos os
problemas do catolicismo sociais de
eliminação da diferença.
Lev
>> exato. Mas o Cristo não é igreja
católica. Esse é o bom. Uhum. É o que nó
tá falando. Cristo não é igreja
católica. A Igreja Católica veio bem
depois com uma estrutura de poder
enorme.
Então eu acho que tem essa diferença.
Cristão, mas não
>> eu acho interessante pros budistas
entender como que essas questões
aparecem dentro do próprio budismo, né?
Porque elas, na verdade, são questões
humanas.
Então, eu tenho também pensado muitas
vezes sobre isso, porque no budismo tem
muitas linhagens,
ele tem linhagens que adotam a feições
de diferentes culturas, né? natural. O
Bud é o mesmo, mas até a representação
física dele estava diferente.
Então esse é um ponto delicado assim,
mas eu tenho procurado entender isso do
seguinte modo. Existe a experiência da
visão,
que é o que o Buda transmite,
e existe o caminho que nos leva à
experiência da visão.
Então, o caminho que nos leva à
experiência da visão, ele começa no
lugar onde nós estamos. Então, se nós
estamos imersos dentro de uma cultura,
eh, o caminho tem que dialogar com
aquela cultura e mostrar como que aquilo
se vincula com a experiência da visão.
Então, em diferentes lugares, diferentes
pessoas também, vamos supor, Brasil é
uma coisa muito grande. Diferentes eh
culturas dentro do país vão ter que
dialogar de uma forma diferente. o
budismo vai ter que dialogar com aquela
realidade daquelas pessoas.
E eh e como todas as expressões, ou
seja, todas as bolhas de realidade, elas
são expressões do aspecto último, então
eu posso naturalmente chegar em qualquer
lugar e vincular aquilo facilmente com a
visão e aí surge um caminho
para aquilo, sendo que o caminho ele não
começa do início.
Eu vou até para explicar para vocês o
que que significa isso. Ele começa do
fim.
Por exemplo, tu tá no no aspecto último,
aí tu chega numa comunidade
eh específica e tu fala do aspecto útil.
As pessoas podem entender, podem não
entender. Se elas não entenderam, tu
explica a coisa que vem imediatamente
antes. Se elas não entenderam, tu
explica o que vem imediatamente antes.
Quando tu vê, tu chegou no lugar onde a
pessoa tá, vem vindo de ré, entende? E
aí surge, aí a pessoa entende aquilo,
vai naquela direção. Eu acho que os
católicos fizeram isso também.
Então eles encontraram um jeito de
explicar o o Fábio, que é esse teólogo,
ele tava contando o que que os,
aliás, nem foi ele, foi o Luiz Gonzaga
tava contando como o que que os
católicos contaram pros indígenas, pros
indígenas se entregarem.
e é assim, eles chegaram de cada então
aquilo foi um fenômeno muito
extraordinário.
Eles disseram: "O nosso Deus
mandou nos mandou aqui para trazer
para vocês uma mensagem sobre os
antepassados de vocês, os que já
morreram.
Eles estão em grande agonia e eles só
vão ultrapassar esse sofrimento se vocês
abraçarem a fé.
Então, nosso Deus infinitamente
compassivo nos mandou aqui. Aí eles
eles olharam aquilo, eles tem o culto
aos antepassados, o respeito pelo ser,
etc. Eles viram aquele fenômeno muito
extraordinário. Então eles viram do céu
vieram esses seres e eles trouxeram essa
mensagem.
Aí eles tiveram essa tendência a
simplesmente aceitar, né?
aquilo quebrou eles
assim, não sei como é que eles disseram
aquilo em português e os indígenas
entenderam em guarani. Isso é um outro
assunto.
Mas vamos supor que teve uma hora que
eles se entenderam.
>> Aí teve aqueles que resistiram, teve os
indígenas que resistiram.
Isso é conhecido assim. tem várias
histórias para
Mas então tem esse tem esse aspecto do
do cabinho assim, né? Então, por
exemplo, dentro da tradição budista, eu
acho muito importante que a gente
entenda que diferentes tradições elas
estão preservando o que o mestre
ensinou. Então elas elas preservam o
caminho,
mas o caminho ele combina na visão.
Então é assim, tem alguns caminhos que
eles são o cultivo da visão, tem outros
caminhos que são o cultivo de alguma eh
experiência que os mestres trouxeram,
que aponta a visão, mas as pessoas estão
repetindo as práticas e repetindo os
processos, porque o o o foco não é
especificamente a visão, mas É,
a estrutura, por exemplo, dentro do zen,
vamos simplificar assim, nós temos o
chocre, que é a cerimônia da manhã, nós
temos a meditação em silêncio,
essencialmente isso aí eu medito,
trabalho e faço a cerimônia. Essa é a
vida. Eu vou ritualizando tudo,
banheiro, banho, comida, tudo. Eu vou
rezando e vou fazendo isso e pratico em
silêncio. Esse é um caminho. Eu me visto
em preto. Eu vivo como um afastado.
Enfim, o foco não é chegar nas pessoas,
ajudar as pessoas, não é esse o foco. O
foco é eu purificar minha própria
prática. Então essa é uma forma, é uma
estrutura. Se tu seguir aquilo, tá
seguindo o o Zenho. Se tu não seguir,
não tá seguindo. É assim. Aí tu pensa,
bom, mas como é que o mestre Dogen
falaria sobre o catolicismo? Ele não
fala porque ele ele propõe aquele
caminho. E o que que ele diria das
deidades tibetanas? Ele não vai falar em
nada disso porque aquilo não não
pertence. Então ele nega, ele vai dizer:
"Olha, se você quiser seguir o Zen,
abandone tudo isso e siga o Zen."
Aí vem os tibetanos e vão dizer: "Olha,
tá praticando estados mentais,
melhor praticar lucidez,
melhor entender a realidade como é, aí
aprender a criar as realidades.
É assim, não adianta tu ficar
estabilizando estados mentais.
Se tu quiser seguir aquilo, segue lá com
eles.
Mas a coisa que realmente importa, que
realmente a boa, é isso aqui. Então,
cada caminho vai falar do seu caminho.
Por quê? Porque ele vai dizer: "Olha, o
melhor caminho é o Zem, mas eu sigo
aqui.
Se o melhor caminho é o Zem, eu vou
passar pro Zem. Aí se as pessoas estão
lá no Zem e dizem: "Não, o melhor
caminho é o tibetân, mas eu vou seguir
aqui". Não, melhor caminho tibetano,
passar os tibetanos. Então, quem tá no
seu lugar pensa que aquele lugar é o
melhor.
E daí surge uma tensão, uma tensão
sectária, é inevitável,
entende? É assim, mas aí quando surge
uma tensão sectária, o que que surge? Aí
surge o movimento não sectário.
Eu acho isso maravilhoso, que tudo se
equilibra. Aí tem o movimento rimeo
dentro do Tibete mesmo, que é assim,
pessoal, cada tradição deveria preservar
as outras todas, porque elas são
riqueza.
Se eu tomo aspirina, eu posso preservar
os outros medicamentos, porque eles são
útis. Eu não tô usando aquilo, mas eu
vou eu vou preservar o método de
produção, entender como é que como é que
é usado, que benefício, eu acho que
ainda vou tomar mais um aqui,
entender o benefício que aquilo é é
causado, né? Sem precisar ficar
comparando um com o outro, achando que
um é melhor que por quê? Porque tem
facilidades maiores de um jeito ou de
outro. É um processo assim, né? Mas
vamos supor, todas as medicinas em
princípio, elas têm por referência
saúde.
Então esse caminho de focar a saúde, o
que que é? Eu acho ele crucial. Então eu
sempre tenho a sensação de que a gente
primeiro deve olhar a saúde
e ali se a gente não consegue, então a
gente faz uma prática para chegar ali.
Mas a gente não começa por uma grande
complicação de aprender farmácia,
aprender todas as medicações para depois
pensar em saúde. Eu acho que não é
assim, né? Então a gente vai direto.
Então isso é um outro jeito. Então, por
exemplo, o SEB tem trabalhado de forma
não secária desde a sua fundação, né?
Desde do ano de 86,
a gente trabalha de modo não sectário,
incluindo a ciência, filosofia,
expressões culturais várias. Por quê?
Porque todas as aparências elas são
sagradas. Elas podem não parecer, mas
são.
Quando a gente conversa com as várias
expressões, nós nos enriquecemos. Eu
acho super bom isso e a gente tem tido a
felicidade de receber a visita de
diferentes mestres de diferentes
tradições. A gente recebeu todas a gente
já recebeu o pessoal tervado do
que vive nas florestas, anda de pé
descalço enrolado mantos amarelos,
cabeça raspada, monges.
E
aí nós também recebemos, praticamos o
Zen com diferentes mestres,
mestres diferentes tradições porque tem
isso, né? Aí o Zen vai se ampliando.
Então a gente teve essa proximidade
muito grande. Eu digo teve, mas a gente
tem né?
E
por exemplo, nós tivemos ordenação de
Mesen dentro do CEB.
no espaço do CB, no templo do Seber, né?
Agora nós vamos receber o Socan, que é o
superior da América Latina, ele vai o
Socavate lá no onde nós estamos morando.
Ele vai lá. Infelizmente eu não vou
estar lá no dia, eu vou est em viagem,
não tenho como evitar, porque eu acho
que ele vai lá no período do Eric, né?
Eu não vou est lá, eu gostaria de
encontrá-la.
Então, a gente tá com essa com essa
vontade de se encontrar e conversar,
mas eu tenho amigos que estão longe
dizerem em diferentes abordagens, eles
estão lá, nós somos amigos, a gente se
encontra. Às vezes eu vou numa cidade,
eu convido eles, a gente faz, tá numa
mesma roda e conversa junto sobre
aquilo. E não tem diferença nenhuma.
Tudo sabe, a gente olha
porque tendo essa abertura, eles têm
essa abertura, a gente se sente super
bem assim, tem nenhum problema. Os
tibetanos também a gente já recebeu os
Gelúpa, agora chegaram uma delegação
maravilhosa assim de mongescoppa
que vieram, fizeram a cerimônia de eh
as mandalas de areia, né? Super lindo.
Aqui tem uma foto linda, né? que eu acho
que todo mundo viu essa foto lá no
caminho do meio daquela do lado de fora
ali que a Mariana mandou para uma foto
super bonita
e a gente tem uma felicidade, a gente se
encontra com eles é assim e ainda assim
surge alguma coisa, né? Tem
estranhamentos porque são diferentes
abordagens tá?
Dentro do Guelug estudar o Lan de saída.
A gente não estuda o LAN Rim.
Aí eles vão falar: "Mas que budismo é
este? Você vocês não estudam Lim? A
gente não estuda Lim.
É um método compacto eh que foi criado
eh quando
a Ticha reinstalou o Bodil no Tibet.
Então ele é a base das tradições novas.
Nós uma tradição antiga.
Então a gente estuda palavras do meu
professor perfeito.
A gente não estuda lá,
isso é o equivalente, mas eventualmente
a gente estuda o ornamento, a preciosa
liberação de Gampão Popa, que também
pertence à tradições novas, né?
E que ele se origina do Limin. Estuda
isso. Nós tem uma tradução, nós estamos
estudando isso há muito tempo. É uma
base bem interessante,
maravilhosa,
né? Mas aquilo é caminho. Então, eh, a
gente tem essa, esse foco de olhar, o
ponto último. Procura não se enrolar
isso, né? Não que isso não seja útil.
Então, pode ter um momento que aquilo é
útil, mas eu acho
melhor estudar as coisas complicadas eh
a partir de um ponto muito próximo do
ponto último, porque aí tudo fica mais
claro, mais rápido, mais fácil de
entender. Caso contrário, a gente começa
a perguntar: "Mas o mundo dos semideuses
existe mesmo?" A gente começa assim,
entende?
Não existe, mas enfim, não existe. Aí
ele tá aqui. A gente pode ver, não. Só
os grandes mestres vem o mundo do
semideus.
Nós vemos quando muito o reino humano e
o reino dos animais, mas quando olhamos
pros animais nós vemos os animais com
parte do mundo humano e não a gente não
vê eles mesmos no mundo deles.
E os seres famentos a gente também não
vê. E os seres dos infernos a gente não
vê. E os deuses a gente não vê. Então, a
gente começa assim, por quê? Porque nós
temos um um sentido denso. Quando a
gente não entende os aspectos mais
profundos, a gente tem uma densidade em
tudo. Aí fica uma linguagem difícil, mas
o Lrin é para isso, porque não tem a
visão. Então, começa com uma coisa
assim.
Oente né pessoal?
>> Eu acho
>> quem que vai se conectar hoje dia no
acidente com isso aí, faz ninguém.
>> Mas aí se tu disser que aquilo são
estados psicológicos, hum, que
interessante. Sim. Aí aquilo é assim, é,
é como por exemplo, tu vai aprender
sobre os deuses gregos, né? Porque tem o
Olimpo e tem Júpiter, mas Júpiter
estaria onde? Ah, Júpiter só os grandes
praticantes é que vem Júpiter, vocês não
podem ver Júpiter para Mas e por que que
essa tradição afundou e veio a tradição
católica, né? Não, não afundou. É só
certos seres é que são capazes de
entender. Nós estamos regidos pelo
zodíco com todos os deuses gregos e as
pessoas pensam que isso não funciona,
mas tá lá.
[Música]
assim. Então, aí surge esse ponto. Mas,
enfim, o o aspecto não sectário,
ele é um aspecto que vai ganhando força
na medida que te aproxima de um ponto
mais sutil.
>> E na tradição bom também, né?
>> E a tradição bom também é desafiada e
também produz desafios todas essas
tradições. Por quê? Porque eu acho que
uma chave nisso, pessoal, que vai
aliviar nós é assim, existe os caminhos
e existe a realização do caminho, existe
a visão. No budismo é chamado de visão,
entendeu? Então, quem olhar desde um
ponto elevado, vê todos os caminhos e
sorrir pros caminhos, não acha que
aquilo esteja errado. Mas quem tá
seguindo um caminho, começa a ouvir
sobre o outro, aquilo joga dúvida. Eu
não sei se eu sigo aqui, porque tem
outro que tá ali, ele está dizendo que
tá ótimo, tá o ar fresco, tá tudo bem,
eu vou passar para lá. Aí nós ficamos
atrapalhados, entende? E assim, então eh
o a recomendação sempre do próprio da
Leilama é assim: "Não troque de tradição
religiosa, não troque a sua prática, mas
siga da melhor forma a sua própria
prática".
Não virem budista. Essa é a recomendação
do leilão.
A gente pode seguir, pode não seguir,
mas ele vai dizer isso.
Mas se vocês virarem budistas, sejam
bons budistas.
Mas é assim, a gente precisa entender
que o caminho ele não deveria ser
sectário. O caminho ele é uma bênção que
alguém recebeu algum tempo e preservou
aquilo e aquela bênção segue
reverberando né?
Eh, tô atualizando, você tá sempre,
né? Existe algo que seja uma uma forma
de funcionamento e inteligência da mente
de alguma forma simplifica as coisas
coisas? Porque ontem a gente tava tava
falando, a gente tava conversando sobre
como é difícil tá estar e trabalhar
dentro do pensamento complexo, né?
Porque você tem que levar várias vários
elementos em consideração para conseguir
encontrar um caminho em comum, né? Mas
quando eu digo só a minha verdade é só
eh só existe um caminho que é o que leva
Deus que é esse e todos os outros não
levam. Então, dentro
>> dentro, né, dessa perspectiva sectária e
dogmática do mon de de algumas
expressões eh do monoteísmo, eh isso
seria sempre ligado a uma estrutura de
poder que é humana
>> ou existe uma forma de inteligência que
vê nessa exclusão dos diferentes e da
diferença uma maneira mais
simples ou prática, não sei, de poder
conduzir as suas as situações Eu não sei
se eu fui clara assim.
>> Eu acho que sim. Eu acho que eu entendi.
É que assim, as estruturas de poder elas
vão existir,
porque onde existe um grupo tem uma
estrutura de poder.
Se aquilo tá se mantendo é porque tem
algumas coisas que estão sendo
preservadas. Então as estruturas de
poder existem junto com os grupos. É
inevitável isso,
mas eu acho que quanto mais aberta a a
organização, mais capaz de digerir, de
lidar com as várias coisas, melhor,
muito mais estável.
Assim mesmo os impérios, se vocês vão
olhar, né, para o bem ou para o mal, os
impérios eles são estruturas que se
preservaram por um longo tempo, porque
eles foram capazes de chegar nos
diferentes lugares e melhorar
de algum modo, trazer alguma coisa e
fazer tudo funcionar melhor, né? do
império,
império romano, ele ajudou, ele foi
chegando com estradas, com comércio e as
pessoas se sentiram enriquecendo as suas
vidas, porque viam coisas de outros
lugares que não existiam antes e eles
viram que eles estavam, a vida deles
estava melhorando.
E aí vem os comerciantes, vem as pessoas
falando outras línguas, vai se
misturando com as línguas deles, vão
surgindo línguas locais e aquilo vai
existindo. Parece que é melhor. Então, o
Império Romano ele ele se tornou uma
coisa como os outros impérios, né? Se
vocês vão olhar o império otomano, per
otomano, ele preservou diferentes
tradições religiosas. O o sultão, o a
guarda pessoal do sultão era composta de
cristãos,
porque ele não acreditava que ele
tivesse suficiente segurança se a guarda
dele fosse de islâmicos, que os
islâmicos poderiam aspirar o poder. Mas
se ele tá cercado por cristãos, os
cristãos não têm chance. Eles são
poucos, eles são só guarda pessoal,
então eles não vão criar um golpe de
estado. Então o Sultão era preservado e
aquilo era tão interessante porque ele
ele pedia um homem cristão eh de cada
família cristã que tava dentro do
império otomano. Então, ele preservava
as regiões cristãs, mas ele pedia eh que
eles mandassem os soldados, os guardas
que iam compor essa guarda pessoal para
ele. Então ele também tinha as famílias
lá. Se desse qualquer coisa, ele podia
pressionar as famílias.
tinha um uma coisa, uma armadilha assim,
mas eles preservaram as várias
tradições.
Então esse é um aspecto, um aspecto do
império. O império, por exemplo, mongol
também, ele se preservou por um longo
tempo, preservando as várias tradições,
mas ele preservou as tradições depois
que elas sucumbiram, né? Primeiro elas
perderam o poder, aí ele mantém a
tradição espiritual, que é um pouco como
os chineses estão fazendo com o Tibete.
O Tibet perdeu a capacidade política
ligada à tradição budista. Aí tudo bem,
vocês podem revisar, não tem problema
nenhum. Aí tá tudo OK. Estão submetidos
ao império, né?
Então hoje vocês vão ver o império
chinês, que não é chamado assim, mas ele
é.
Ele chegando nos vários lugares do mesmo
modo, ele chega com comércio, ele chega
melhorando a vida das pessoas. Aí no fim
o vínculo que as pessoas têm para
estudar, para melhorar a economia e
aprender o chinês, por exemplo, mandar
os filhos para cá ou para lá, eles vão
melhorando as vidas deles. Então,
lentamente devagar
aqueles locais, eles se tornam eh se
tornam satélites de um grande centro de
poder. E assim os impérios se
estabelecem. Eles não se estabelecem
pela força, eles estabelecem pelo
benefício que eles vão estabelecendo,
né? Então, essas estruturas de poder,
elas vão surgindo assim, desse modo, né?
E a e a religião católica, ela
estabeleceu isso. Só que aquilo ficou
meio assim, porque eles tinham uma
exclusão. Foi um período também de
escravatura, né? Mas essa escravatura
não é a escravatura apenas dos
africanos, que a gente não entende bem
isso, não foi, pessoal? Os europeus
estavam escravizados também, atacados,
escravizados, aprisionados de um modo
bem semelhante.
E curiosamente eles eram eles eram
atacados, escravizados e vendidos pros
africanos, pros povos do norte da
África.
Era assim. E também eles eram
bom, eu não vou, essa história da
escravatura ela é longa. Então, por
exemplo, do mesmo modo que os ingleses
escravizavam os africanos, os vikings
escravizavam os os ingleses, vendiam
como escravos em diferentes lugares e
criaram ele. Eles estudaram isso,
estudaram a genética. Porque a os gens
femininos,
eles, eu não sei bem como é que é, eles
se preservam e eles mesmo misturados com
os gênos masculinos, porque as pessoas
elas
e é isso. Então, tu consegue determinar
que os gens e da Islândia hoje eles são
gens dos povos anglo-saxões.
Eles não são gens vikings, enquanto que
os masculinos são vikings. Então
continua essa divisão e consegue aquilo
é uma arqueologia genética, né? Então
eles dis tudoam isso aí eles viram que
as mulheres foram aprisionadas
nessa região e foram levadas. Então tem
uma estatística, os gens anglosaxões
femininos são muito mais numerosos do
que os gens anglo do que os gênos
vikings femininos.
Então eles viram, os homens vieram de
lá, roubaram as mulheres
e venderam elas para os na Islândia. São
os dinamarqueses.
Dominaram os dinamarqueses e
então a Groenlândia, por exemplo, é
Dinamarca. Por quê? Quer ver quem?
Aí tem que Groelândia com a Dinamarca.
Que que é?
Vamos ver.
Eles davam uma passadinha na Inglaterra,
levava as meninas, já iam povoando
aquelas regiões.
Então tinha essa escravatura. Aí tem
relatos bem claros,
por exemplo, de uma princesa anglo-saxã
que foi aprisionada pelos vikings, foi
vendida como escrava, foi comprada por
um uma pessoa muito rica
que teve um filho com ela.
Esse filho, e ela não falava, ela é como
se ela fosse muda, ela se manteve
muda.
Mas um dia esse eu vou chamar de marido
dela viu ela falando com o filho.
Ela viu que ela que ela falava, ele viu
que ela falava.
Então ela falava em Anglosaxon
com o filho. Aí ele perguntou para ela,
aí ela contou que ela era filha do rei
de lá.
Aí ele pegou o filho,
levou lá e o filho encontrou o avô que
era vivo ainda
e o e ficou com o avô ficou com o filho
e o avô se tornou rei de lá também na
sequência.
É o o neto, né? O neto se tornou.
Então isso são relatos que tão que tão
escritos com nomes, com datas direitinho
assim. Então era um período desse tipo,
né? Então, houve essa escravatura.
Então, os cristãos nesse período, eles
estavam no meio disso, né?
A Igreja Católica tava no meio disso e a
e o cristianismo
tava assim, né? Então, um pouco depois
começaram as descobertas. Então, esse
período da descoberta, pessoal, ele
coincide com outras transformações
históricas muito interessantes, assim,
que é também a perseguição, a
intensificação da perseguição aos judeus
na Europa, uns poucos anos antes, assim,
poucos anos, é 4 ou 5 anos antes das
grandes descobertas, das viagens do
descobrimento, houve uma perseguição
maciça dos judeus na península ibérica,
que era o último lugar que ele se escond
Banha
tem judeu que é sempre entre processou
lembrar
pelo
>> é é
fin ou emigrar ou
então
>> é é isso de preservar
é isso mesmo. Mas aí tem uma visão,
não chegar,
>> mas daí tem a visão, por exemplo, o
Penin foi um dos que me chamou atenção
disso. Ele mostrou como, por exemplo, a
ilha de Fernando Noronha. Fernando
Noronha é um nome eh novo judeu.
Ele é um é um judeu que adotou um nome
português. Uhum. Amor,
então eu tinha um código
dessas dessas lesões que é assim, os
nomes portugueses correspondentes a
frutas,
legumes,
árvores, eles são nomes, são novos
nomes.
Então,
aí tinha isso, que a as viagens do
descobrimento foram financiadas
pelos judeus que dominavam já o sistema
econômico
>> e por isso eles eram eles eram
favorecidos porque os católicos não
podiam emprestar juros. tá proibido a
usura pela tradição católica. Aí os
judeus,
>> então os católicos é como se fosse uma
falha moral tu cobrar juros.
Mas os judeus podiam fazer isso. Então
os judeus dominaram o sistema bancário e
aí eles eram amados e ao mesmo tempo
hostilizados porque eles prosperavam. Aí
tinha épocas que a sociedade tava em
crise, mas os judeus estavam tavam
prósperos porque eles manejavam o
sistema econômico.
Então de tanto em tanto eles eram
perseguidos e e pilhados.
Então houve esse tempo que eles foram
perseguidos. Então se diz que eles
financiaram as viagens do descobrimento
porque eles precisavam de outros
lugares. Então vocês vão ver lá em
Recife chegando os judeus antes de
chegar em Nova York eles chegaram em
Recife. Então tem lá o local a gente
pode passar lá fotografar no centro de
Recife.
Ah, eu tive lá, vi aquilo,
não vou chamar de sinagoga, eu acho que
é uma sinagoga.
Eles eles passaram lá, aí ficaram um
tempo, resolveram ir para Nova York
assim, porque os Estados Unidos nesse
tempo era também uma terra livre e tavam
e eles fundaram Nova Yorkmente
>> aí se vocês olharem não mudou muito
porque o domínio do sistema financeiro
continua e essa é Uma das razões que se
diz que os governos seguem apoiando o
Estado de Israel contra qualquer
conexão,
conexão
ética moral
porque o sistema econômico ele é como se
fosse um deep state, né, que eles vão
chamar. Então tem isso e mais outras
grandes empresas que elas terminam, elas
são transnacionais, elas não são
nacionais, elas não são limitadas pela
nacionalidade, elas têm interesses
próprios
e eles dominam esse sistema.
Mas esse é um outro assunto.
Um outro assunto.
A gente foi bomante
p
É que isso tá ligado a esse tema que a
gente tava olhando de sectarismo, né?
como é que essas estruturas se dão, como
é que o estrutura de poder surge dentro
da igreja católica. Então, surgiu isso.
Essa é uma, eu gosto de ouvir o Fábio
Bento também, convidar o Fábio Bento
para falar sobre isso. É um teólogo, ele
estudou tudo isso em Roma.
Ele conhece bem essas questãos,
mas aí tem essa estrutura. Mas aí, por
exemplo, tu tá no meio dessa estrutura e
o cristianismo cresce ou o budismo
cresce e aquilo vem junto com o
imperador a choca e eles vão dominando
outros povos e vão ampliando e vem os
éditos de achoque, as colunas com as
leis budistas,
né? Mas aquilo é caminho.
Aí essas pessoas elas acessam visão,
elas talvez não acessem, elas estão
matando umas outras e estão tentando
consolidar alguma coisa, né? Então o
campo de sectarismo é esse. Como é que a
gente escapa do campo do sectarismo? A
gente olha a visão.
O caminho é importante, mas vamos
pensar. O caminho termina quando a gente
chega ao final. Então nós nós precisamos
olhar pro final. Não, não deveria
simplesmente ficar cultivando e
preservando um tipo de caminho.
Assim, o caminho não foi criado por um
caminhante, ele foi criado por alguém
que percorreu tudo e chegou ao final.
Ponto final é o ponto. Então aí
repentinamente aparece o que aparece a
tradição do Zotin que trata do final do
caminho
de saída, trata disso. Então isso é a
culminância do budismo também.
Aí nós vamos encontrar, por exemplo, tem
muitos
judeus que se interessam pelo budismo.
Por quê? Porque a tradição judaica,
o aspecto secreto da tradição judaica,
começa a encontrar Deus no vazio.
Então eles encontram muitos paralelos.
Então vocês vão encontrar muitos judeus
estudando budismo.
>> Aí tem muitas tradições que vão falar
disso. Aí tu escuta a tradição guarani.
Aí eles vão falar do céu, vão falar do
barqueiro no céu, como é que começa
aquilo. Tu começa a olhar aquilo, uau, é
muito parecido. tu consegue ler aquilo,
né, e ver esses parales assim, é muito
bonito isso. Então, eu acho que eh esse
aspecto
eh eh o aspecto sectário é uma doença do
caminho, né? Mas ele é explicável,
porque se tá seguindo o caminho, é
melhor seguir o caminho,
né? É assim. Então, como que uma um
caminho vai se preservar se ele não
procurar se valorizar e sustentar os
praticantes naquilo? Eu acho que tá
certo.
>> O problema é que diz que o outro não é
bem fazer, né?
>> É, é, é. Ele vai até o final e é o
melhor e vai. Mas o outro eh
>> é, eu acho que isso pode ser
problemático, né? Como é que os
tibetanos, especialmente os Gelugba,
resolveram isso, né? Eu acho superábil,
sabe? Por jeito, porque é uma análise
filosófica. Então eles começam a olhar
quais são os pressupostos daquele
caminho.
Então eles dizem: "Esse caminho é
perfeito, ele vai até o fim e ele tem
tais pressupostos. Se ele tem esses
pressupostos, ele não tem outros
pressupostos, ele tem esse. Então isso
delimita o caminho. Mas quando delimita
o caminho, eh, quando eu digo delimita,
também limita.
Aí ele faz isso, ele não faz outra
coisa, né? É mais ou menos assim, o jogo
de futebol, pessoal, tem uma cancha
gramada, tem uma bola, duas goleiras, 11
de cada lado. Ele não é vôlei, ele é
futebol, né? Então eu caracterizo aquilo
direitinho, o que que eles fazem e o que
que eles não fazem também. Eles não
jogam uma bola para cima, não tem um
cestto, não tem uma tabela. É assim,
eles jogam 11 contra 11, é uma outra
coisa.
Mas eu posso ter a felicidade de ganhar
um jogo? Posso. O outro pode ter a
felicidade de ganhar um jogo? Pode. O
outro também pode. Pode. Só que são
jogos diferentes.
É assim. Mas todos eles conduzem a um
nível de felicidade pela vitória.
Mas são caminhos diferentes.
Aí no budismo a gente vai dizer: "OK, tu
pode seguir esse caminho, mas tu também
pode sentar em meditação,
acessar sua felicidade direto."
Esse é um ponto interessante, porque a
diz, se tu pode ter uma felicidade
porque tu ganha um jogo, essa felicidade
ela veio porque a bola entrou
ou é um estado interno? Diz: "Não, é um
estado interno."
Se tu consegue ter essa felicidade como
estado interno, então faz assim, ó. Faz
assim e vê se isso aparece. Aí tu
treina, aí aparece.
É, não. Aí tu nem pensa em bola
entrando. É,
é. Aí tu entende que aquilo é um estado
mental, aí tu aprende. Então
é muito mais fácil.
Isso são os casinas. As casinas são
estados mentais que ganham esse nome
porque tu sabe que estão dentro.
E aí começa o caminho, começa o o mundo
da forma, que é o mundo dos meditantes.
Você fala: "Então dá um trabalhão, ele
treinou, fez não sei quanta coisa só
para chegar e pum! Tem uma felicidade
super curta em alguma coisa". Mas se ele
sentar aqui agora sem precisar esse
trabalhão todo,
ele recebe essa transmissão porque ele
já viu, ele sabe que é felicidade.
Clique
au
mas surgem 20 estados meditativos desse
tipo.
Mas aí ele vai fazendo isso e ele cansa
que eles p Eu não quero aqui. é tudo
igual felicidade alegria compaixão
amor, etc. É um estado que eu crio,
aí eu faço aquilo e depois saio,
né? Isso. Cada um desses estados, eu
preciso fazer um esforço para ficar ali.
E ainda que eu faço um esforço, que ele
termina.
Então,
pessoal, deve ter coisa mais sutil.
Aí começa o mundo que é descrito, o
mundo da não forma. Eu di assim, eu não
quero estados mentais, eu quero a
condição natural.
Aí o que que é a condição natural?
Condição natural é o espaço infinito.
Aí a pessoa clean, espaço infinito.
Aí a pessoa descobre que o espaço
infinito também é uma, ele ligou, puxou
uma alavanca, né? Aí ele vai paraa
consciência infinita.
Aí ele vai pro nada. Aí ele vai pro
pensar, nem pensar, nem não pensar.
Todos esses estados são construídos
também.
Aí ele diz: "Eu abandono, eu saí e
chutei o pau da barraca. Agora eu quero
santar,
né?" Aí ele diz: "Não, eu volto pro
mundo comum. Isso aí eu tô perdendo meu
tempo total. O que que é o mundo comum?"
Eu fazendo esforço aqui para obter um
estado mental que é melhor pior. Mas eu
quero morrer. Aí tu não consegue morrer.
A tua mente não apaga. Aí tu diz: "Não,
eu vou apagar a mente. Então vem niroda.
Vou apagar a mente. Aí tu pratica
niroda.
Niroda é um estado super sutil no qual a
pessoa deixa de respirar, coração cessa,
mas tu não morre.
Aí tu, aí tem as instruções exatas como
pratica niroda. A próxima vez que eu
vier nós vamos fazer um laboratório de
nós opção vontade para morrer.
Aí a Neirada. Então a mãe do Rimpochi,
ela passou por essa experiência.
Tem um livro publicado disso, né? Então,
a mente da pessoa, ela não depende do
corpo. Então, o corpo é abandonado. A
mente da pessoa sai livre, mas ela tem
um compromisso de retornar.
Então, ela anda livre pelo mundo da
morte e ela, pum, e o corpo bate e
começa a bater de novo, tudo funciona de
novo. Ela, ô, fui lá, trouxe umas
mensagens aí para você. Aí a mãe do
rebocha trouxe umas mensagens, né?
Então, foi assim. E então esse é um
mundo extraordinário que é o mundo de
Niroda. Aí o Buda passa por isso
e o Boda diz: "Isso aí também é fake,
pessoal. Uma coisa construída.
>> Tem um livro dela
chama Delog.
Delog é é esse praticante, né, que anda
por esses mundos.
Então aí tem a
aí ele volta, né? Aí o Banda se deu
conta, não, todos esses estados mentais
são construídos, mas aí ele vê que há a
grande abertura a partir do qual os
múltiplos estados brotam. E ele vê que
ele tava sempre praticando a sabedoria
que vinha desse estado. Por isso ele
diz: "Isso aqui é fake, isso aqui é
fake, isso aqui é fake, isso aqui é
fake". Aí ele se dá conta dessa lucidez.
Aí ele vai dizer: "Eu tô liberto,
liberto de entrar em estados mentais
particulares. Eu tô operando desde esse
lugar livre, eu não tô num estado
particular".
Aí ele decreta a iluminação,
ele decreta liberação.
Pode descrever isso. Então, o budismo é
radicalmente uma
liberação de estados mentais
particulares.
Isso é chamado liberação.
E nós estamos vagueando dentro de
estados mentais construídos de um pro
outro, do pro outro, do pro outro,
assim, de um modo, se tu começa a
perceber isso aí, tu pode se sentir
focado de repente, pá, eu quero parar
essa coisa de sair de um estado pro
outro. Nenhum estado é qualquer coisa
verdadeira, eu tô minha consciência vai
vagueando e vai dando importância, eu
vou indo de um lugar pro outro. Como é
que é isso? Então, quando a pessoa
percebe isso, ela aspira liberação.
Aspirar liberação e tomar refúgio no
Buda, no darme, na sanga para atingir
liberação é o início do caminho.
Por isso que é tão difícil haver
praticantes que tomaram verdadeiramente
o refúgio, porque a pessoa precisa
entender isso, senão ela não entrou
verdadeiramente né?
Aí a gente entra, mas não tá no caminho
ainda. De fato, a gente entra, mas tem
alocentramento, tem uma série de coisas.
Aí o Buda classifica os praticantes em
oito tipos.
Oito tipos de acordo com ele tão andando
agora. Ele sai deles para aquele outro
tipo, depois deles pro outro tipo que
vai até o arhat. Arrhat é aquele que não
responde automaticamente. É como se ele
tivesse uma habilidade da ação de poder,
uma maturidade completa da ação de
poder. Então, as coisas acontecem, ele
não é arrastado pelas coisas,
mas aquilo não é iluminação. Aind.
Então, arrat não esses oito tipos de
praticantes são oito tipos de
praticantes que vão progressivamente
eh ficando mais sofisticados, mas o Buda
ele é um non tipo
tá apaga.
Vamos olhar pro relógio agora é 20 pro
meio-dia. Nós vamos até A gente não tem
um horário.
>> A gente não tem horário.
>> Tu não tem que ir embora aind?
Ô tem dia 50 dia 50.
>> Não, eu eu hoje eu não preciso comer
porque eu já tenho comido todos esses
dias.
Eu
acho
agora fiquei preocupado.
Eu tô me sentindo um pouco magro assim,
um pouco
fraco, né, que é
Ah, não, não. Mas eu queria ainda contar
uma coisa para vocês. Se vocês sentirem
que ainda tem uma energiazinha assim,
>> Sim, eu tenho que continuar sugestando,
>> tá? Então, hoje de manhã eu tava
descrevendo aquele
aquelas preces
ligadas a sabedoria, lucidez, né? Então
eu vou continuar um pouquinho aqui, né?
Então a gente começa
aí, pessoal. Coisa séria.
Muito ver a primeira parte.
>> Vocês perderam a primeira parte porque a
gente fez uma coisa secreta aqui. Aquilo
foi às 2 da manhã aí.
Aqui ninguém dorme.
>> Hum.
aqui.
Eu vou seguir de novo pela prece para
alcançar a cidadela da sabedoria
intrínseca. Hoje eu fazer esse
comentário aqui, né?
É assim, essa é uma parte fácil. Então,
a gente pensa este nome é o nome
glorioso né?
>> É, é verdade. Eu não me dava bem conta,
mas isso aqui realmente uma prece para
alcançar a cidadela da sabedoria
intrínseca, da sabedoria intrínseca,
pessoal, é o que o Buda atingiu. Por
quê? porque ele viu aqueles estados
mentais todos como construídos.
Esse é o ponto, né? Aí ele atinge a
cidadela da sabedoria intrínseca, que é
o lugar através do que ele vê as
artificialidade.
Então eu vou descrever para vocês as
quatro iniciações.
Então aqui a gente começa com a visão,
depois a audição
e aí o que eh o aspecto onírico da mente
que cria coisas, né? Então o a nossa
prática eh tudo aquilo que aparece como
visão, eu reconheço como uma
manifestação luminosa, né? É assim, mas
aqui ele trabalha mais no nível no nível
do pragamita, né? que é negar a
realidade daquilo.
Ele não tá vendo ainda o aspecto
luminoso, né? Mas eu vou começar nessa
base que é como se fosse a categoria do
Prage na Paranita.
Eu vou explicar o aspecto luminoso
em 20 minutos.
É assim,
o tempo não é grande, mas é assim.
É, é que vocês já ouviram essas aulas
tudo nas outras vidas. Eu só tô
lembrando aqui agora.
Então não esqueçam
a tem um intencivão.
Então aí eu queria assim, eu só vou
mencionar, né, vocês já ouviram isso nas
outras vidas, mencionar o aspecto das
várias
das várias voltas do caminho. Então tem
primeira, segunda, terceira volta do
dharma, né? Então o prna paranita na
tradição guelucra ele é visto como
segunda volta do dharma,
não a terceira.
A terceira é o aspecto luminoso da
realidade. Mas o pranita é visto como se
fosse a segunda volta do dharma, porque
eu eu diria assim que a segunda volta do
dharma é a vacuidade malmurada,
né? Aí quando diz mesa não é mesa,
cadeira na cadeira, tapete na tapete,
isso aqui não é uma área de retiro,
vamos respeitar, não é?
>> É, é assim, eu isso aí nós vamos tirando
aquilo que parece que é, entende
que coisa horrível, né? É o mesmo nome
que ninguém sabe o que que é Paris de
fato. É uma construção da mente das
pessoas, né? Assim,
então aí vem assim: "O que quer que
apareça de fato com objetos visíveis ao
olho, tudo no mundo externo, embora
apareça, descanse sem tomar isso como
sendo real."
Então eu tô criticando a aparência
porque eu tô considerando que a
aparência é real. Aí tem essa interface
que a gente usa aqui, que eu acho é uma
chave pra gente poder compreender, que é
a bolha.
Então, por exemplo, nós estamos
entendendo que aqui é uma construção que
tá já tá tremendo, né? Porque ela vai
apagar aqui como local de retiro, né?
Mas aí eu vejo que ela tá construída. Eu
podia dizer: "Olha, pessoal, vocês são
todos uns iludidos. Não tem retiro, não
tem sala de retiro, não tem prédio de
retiro. Isso tudo é uma é uma loucura da
mente de vocês. Vocês entendem? O dia
que vocês tiverem lucidez, vocês não
entram nesse tipo de coisa. Então isso é
a vacuidade mal humorada.
Malumorada.
Tem uma vacuidade bem humorada.
>> É assim, eu vou construir coisas e vou
andar no meio delas, entende?
É assim. Então, tu constrói o quê?
Constrói esse evento no lugar que não é,
né? É assim. Então tô
tem aquela canção,
aquela canção em língua portuguesa que
acho que é do Bom, era uma casa muito
engraçada, não tinha teto, não tinha
nada, ninguém podia entrar nela não,
porque na casa não tinha chão, ninguém
podia
rede, porque na casa não tinha parede,
ninguém podia fazer Pipi porque Pinicro
não tinha,
mas era feita e com muito esmero na rua
dos bobos números zeros. Eu trocaria
assim, mas era feita por muit com muito
esnero na dos magos número zero. Então
essa é a diferença entre o o budismo
entre o prágam a vacuidade malmurada e a
vacuidade luminosa.
Porque em vez de eu pensar que eu tô
sendo um bobo, um trouxa,
eu descubro que eu tô sendo, eu tô
fazendo uma magia criando aquilo. Vocês
entendem?
é muito melhor, pessoal. Então, quando
tu entende que tu tá criando
luminosamente, isso é a terceira volta
do dárbância,
[Música]
a ilusão ali, aquilo é a segunda volta
do Dan. Essa coisa sutil.
>> Isso é, isso não é, isso é
>> isso aí tu tem que entender que isso é,
né? Isso é, tem que pensar, isso aqui
não é o local de retiro, né? Aliás, isso
é o local de retiro, mas na verdade, na
verdade não é,
mas é,
né? Então aí tu começa a olhar como que
aquilo que não é passa a ser, mas não
porque tu quer lutar contra, porque tu
quer dominar o processo luminoso pelo
qual aquilo surge, né? Então esse
aspecto luminoso é o que eu vou falar
agora,
né? Mas aqui nós estamos começando com
um aspecto um pouco hostil que quer que
apareça de fato com objetos visíveis ao
olho. Era uma casa muito engraçada
do
>> tudo no mundo externo, embora apareça,
descanse sem tomar isso como sendo real.
Então parece que então esse é o último,
mas não é o último,
porque criticar o fato de que aquilo não
é não é o ponto, é uma parte do caminho,
mas nenhuma parte do caminho tá separada
do aspecto último. Então como é que isso
segue? A purificação da percepção
dualista é a forma clara, porém vazia da
deidade. Então ele introduz a visão,
ou seja, tem uma deidade que é um estado
mental específico a partir do qual eu
vejo as coisas, começo a ver as coisas
como elas se apresentam e vejo que elas
são construídas e elas são inseparáveis
da própria mente que tá lidando com
aquilo. Então, por exemplo, nós estamos
aqui no retiro lidando com esse fato que
é esse local como um local de retiro,
que é uma ilusão, que isso é, isso não
é, mas isso é, enfim.
Então, lidando com isso, como é que eu
vejo isso?
é uma deidade. Ela é vazia porque ela
não tem um condicionante, mas ela tá
vendo isso.
Então isso é ah isso é
ah isso é gruimpochê. Isso é a mente
essa é a mente livre de desejo e apego
que tá vendo.
Não mostra esse chimarrão para mim.
Então aí surge isso. Então tem uma
deidade, tem um estado lúcido. Esse
estado lúcido é visão.
Essa deidade é visão. Esse é o ponto.
Como é que a visão aparece? Ela aparece
na forma. Quando a forma comum surge, eu
tenho visão.
Mas o aspecto profundo da visão é que
ela é vazia.
É uma é uma forma clara, porém vazia, da
deidade. Então ela é a grande abertura.
Então, dessa grande abertura é que brota
a capacidade de ver os estados
particulares que o Buda viu. Ele viu o
mundo do desejo, depois ele viu, eu sou
um trouxo, eu tô jogando futebol porque
eu quero ficar feliz, mas não, isso não
precisa. Basta eu sentar aqui, toma
felicidade. Aí ele passa pro mundo
interno. Isso é o mundo da forma. E tem
20 samades com nomes específicos
correspondentes ao mundo da forma. sendo
que o último dos samades, aquilo chega a
dar um calafrio na pessoa assim, né? O
último dos samades, eh,
é, o nome é canista,
mas ele é o reino dos deuses. Ao mesmo
tempo, ele é a terra pura do Vagil
Sátana. Por quê? Porque no reino dos
deuses,
da forma aonde surge a igualdade. Então,
nesse o a a sabedoria dos deuses
e do mundo da forma nesse último reino,
eles vêm à igualdade. Ou seja, todas as
formas são a mesma forma. Não porque
elas tenham a mesma aparência, mas
porque todas as formas são formas.
Então não adianta eu saltar de uma forma
para outra, de uma forma para outra,
porque é tudo forma pessoal, entende? Aí
dá um desempeno pá, agora eu quero
felicidade, agora quero isso, quero
aquilo. Mas então forma aquilo surge, é
um tempo e cessa, são estados mentais.
Então é assim, então dentro desse lugar
dos múltiplos estados mentais surge o
ensinamento de vagat purifica a mente
que tá operando com isso. Então essa
purificação ela vem assim, aí vem
vajassato e disse: "Calma pessoal,
calma". Ele não diz isso, mas eu tô aqui
criando.
Calma pessoal, calma. Agora veja,
você reconhece isso? Que que mente é
essa que reconhece isso? E onde que ela
tá?
Aí
ele olha para dentro, como o Buda olhou
para dentro dele mesmo e disse que ele
tava liberto, ele vê que ele tá num
lugar que não é um estado construído e
por isso ele vê os estados construídos.
Se ele tivesse no estado construído, ele
poderia ver algum estado construído e
dizer: "É isso, mas ele tá livre dos
estados construídos. Ele passou por
todos ele". Então ele repousa nesse
lugar livre.
Então esse lugar livre é o que o Buda
encontrou. Esse lugar livre ele vai
chamar de Dharmakai.
Então isso é o primeiro corpo do Buda. O
primeiro corpo do Buda é Darmacaia.
Então nós temos oito consciências.
A consciência de base
que serve para criar os mundos. Por
exemplo, quando nós estamos aqui olhando
aqui como uma sala de meditação, nós
temos uma consciência de base construída
que usa a sensação de que a gente
precisa uma sala de de prática. Por isso
que a gente olha aqui e constrói uma
sala de prática.
Se eu não tiver isso na mente, eu vejo
outra coisa. Por exemplo, daqui acho que
é amanhã, né, que a gente vai embora,
né?
Então amanhã a gente vai olhar para cá e
ele vai dizer: "Uau, será que ficou tudo
bem para eles", né? A gente volta a
olhar com o olho do proprietário.
Então a gente vê perfeitamente que o
nosso olho de sala de prática, ele agora
esgotou a validade. Nós estamos olhando
com um outro olhar e aí nós vemos outras
coisas
assim.
Então, tem uma mente lúcida, que é uma
deidade clara, porém vazia, que vê isso.
Essa deidade clara, porém vazia, que vê
isso é darmacaia.
Então esse é o esse é o Buda. Armmacai é
o Buda. Aqui nós estamos chamando de
guru porché
ordemuni.
Mas essa visão ela substitui as visões
que nos permitem ver coisas
condicionadas,
né? Então eu tenho uma visão particular
que eu vou chamar de de a live de Nana,
que é um conjunto de marcas mentais.
Então eu vou escolher uma secção das
marcas mentais. E quando eu escolho uma
secção das marcas mentais, surge isso
aqui.
Se eu escolher outra secção, surge outra
coisa. Se eu escolher outra secção,
surge outra coisa. Outra coisa assim.
Mas existe uma base livre de onde brota
a lucidez com relação a isso, como eu tô
explicando aqui.
Então, a laia virginana, que é o mundo
condicionado, que eu posso escolher uma
coisa ou outra, é substituído pelo mundo
aberto, onde a lucidez é que surge.
Então, esse ponto ele é super
importante. Por quê? Porque a
experiência
aberta
da grande abertura de onde brota a
sabedoria clara, ela não depende de
olhos ouvidos nariz linguitato.
Ah, a bateria circula.
Será que que é o bustar o carregador?
Eu vou botar aqui
pro lado de cá. Tá perto da da tomada.
Eu
acho que não
poder ver, né?
Mas aí o que que acontece?
Aí nós vemos isso. Então essa
transformação da mente comum
na base
eh lúcida é o o fenômeno da
transformação que aconteceu dentro do
Buda. O Buda, ele abandonou as bases
condicionadas e passou a operar desse
modo.
Então, das quatro iniciações, essa é a
primeira,
é a iniciação da
da
de dar macaia. Aí vem o segundo aspecto.
Segundo aspecto é assim: uma vez que eu
tô eu tomo refúgio nesse lugar amplo,
surge uma vastidão de sabedorias
que não é possível delimitar, porque
cada é olhada desde essa base livre, ela
deixa de ser um obstáculo que me prende
e passa a ser uma sabedoria.
E assim surge o dharma.
O dharma é a aparência que se torna
sabedoria. Então a palavra é a mesma,
né? Darma é aparência, mas dma é
sabedoria. Então surge a mente que é
capaz de ver a a vastidão de aparências
e elas vão se transformando em
sabedoria. Então isso é o segundo corpo
do Buda, que é o corpo que é chamado
como sambogakia.
Esse corpo ele vai manifestar os cinco
de anibudas, cinco budas, cinco
sabedorias.
Aí surge o quê? Sambogaia
na forma corpo do Buda no meio do mundo.
Então o Buda ele se manifesta dentro do
mundo, mas na mente do Buda, o Budo tá
purificado pela visão dele, mas ele
opera como se fosse um agente dentro
normal, dentro do mundo.
E isso é o aspecto também de Jesus
Cristo.
Então, por exemplo, na tradição cristã
não tá descrito os três corpos da
iluminação, mas Jesus Cristo é
seguramente
ahã eh
nirmanaia.
Ele verbaliza isso que ele vai dizer,
eh,
esse não é o meu mundo. Eu não sou desse
mundo, esse não é o meu mundo. Não me
lembro as palavras deles são um
pouquinho diferentes, mas é
essencialmente isso.
Aí ele vai falar do pai.
O pai é da Macaia
e ele expressa
Sambogakai. Ele expressa uma sabedoria
natural que é encantadora.
car
de pai e filhos cristos.
>> É, provavelmente
>> os crentes são
>> é,
mas aí ele surge como o corpo mortal que
não é mortal.
Então, o Nirmanakia
é o corpo causal em meio ao mundo.
Então, esse corpo ele tá dentro do
tempo, porque o mundo aonde ele surge é
o mundo dos três tempos. Então, tem
presente, passado e futuro. Mas
Sambogakaia e Darmakaia não tem
presente, passado e futuro. Então,
Darmacaia é atemporal. Então ele vai se
referir a um pai atemporal,
a uma sabedoria transcendente,
né? Então esse é o Buda. Aí o Buda tá no
meio do mundo e ele vai andar pelos
múltiplos submundos que existe dentro
dos mundos e vai falar para as pessoas
ali dentro explicando, sempre conectando
com o aspecto último.
Então isso é nirmanakaiia.
Então, quando o Buda ele
vive nos três tempos, ele abandona
aquela manifestação, mas essas
manifestações elas são infinitas.
Então, as outras manifestações seguem.
Então, vai surgir um B que tem uma
aparência mais próximo dos tempos que a
gente esteja vivendo. Vão aparecer budas
com outras aparências assim. Então, o
próximo é Maitreia.
Aí, então tem esses três corpos.
Aí surge então o o segundo corpo
que é sambogakaia,
ele substitui
a as nossas identidades.
As nossas identidades, que são a sétima
consciência, elas são essencialmente
jeitos de nós olharmos as coisas.
Asidentidades elas não são propriamente
identidades, mas elas são basamente
Deus. Nós somos praticantes budistas,
por isso nós queremos fazer um retiro,
né? Então, eh, com o olho do praticante
budista, a realidade aparece desse modo
aqui, como nós estamos assim. Se a gente
não tiver esse olho, isso aqui não vai
aparecer, não tem como.
Então, nós temos um olho condicionado.
Pelo nosso olhar condicionado surge isso
e nós nos apegamos.
Isso é a sétima consciência.
Então, a sétima consciência é
substituída pela sabedoria com relação
à base da mente, que é
a dmacaia. Então, daria não brota coisas
comuns, brota lucidez.
Aí com essa mente lúcida, nós entramos
num mundo comum, andando pelos vários
lugares e ajudando seres a compreender
isso. Então, quando a gente entende que
esses três corpos,
sendo que o nerumanaia,
o corpo de manifestação, ele substitui a
mente comum, que é a sexta consciência,
a mente que pensa. Então, ele pensa de
um outro jeito.
Ele substitui a sexta consciência.
Então, nesse momento, quando a gente
substitui a sexta consciência por
Nirmanakaia, sétima por Sambogaka e a
oitava por Darmakia, isso é o que o Buda
fez.
Ele era uma pessoa, ele se transforma
num buda.
Aí nós entendemos, por exemplo, que
essas três consciências
elas são
elas são esbabavicaia, que é chamado
assim esbabavicaia
que é a quarta consciência, sendo que a
quarta consciência
é o quarto corpo, não é a quarta
consciência, é o quarto corpo da
iluminação. quarto corpo da iluminação e
a união dos três, ou seja, o fato eles
vão ser separados e esse é o quarto
corpo. Mas aí quando nós olhamos com
mais cuidado, a gente vê que a sexta
consciência
que é a mente, ela tem cinco
periféricos,
que são olhos ouvidos, na língua e tapa.
Então, a a consciência condicionada em
meio ao mundo, ela pensa com os olhos
ouvidos na lei de língua e tá. Então
aqui, como nós estávamos olhando, né?
gente olha aqui e a gente vê a nossa
sala de meditação.
Eu não raciocino, eu vejo. Então esse é
um é um ponto crucial quando a gente
entende que a mente ela é ela opera por
um periférico que são os olhos e ela vê,
mas quando ela vê ela na verdade tá
criando, ela tá pensando, ela tá
criando. Então os olhos criam. Então
isso é chamado consciência visual.
Consciência visual não é um uma um
reconhecimento, é uma criação.
>> Por isso que a gente usa também aqueles
exemplos do do
cubo né?
A gente reconhece como que a gente tá
criando as coisas.
pegar uma frente
conseguir
com esses aspectos visuais aqui, ó.
A gente vê o cubo,
a gente tem um desenho em duas
dimensões. A gente vê um cubo.
A gente vê um cubo, não vê?
Mais ou menos.
Tu vê um cubo?
E aí tu vê um segundo cubo.
Segundo é assim, a gente pode ver por
baixo, pode ver por cima.
Pois é.
Mas vamos pensar assim, aqui é a base do
cubo.
Isso aqui é a base do cubo, é, né? Aqui
tem uma aresta. Aqui é o topo do cubo,
né? É isso, né? É assim. Agora eu posso
pensar aqui.
Vocês viram?
É que eu tô de lado aqui, eu tenho que
traduzir isso aqui. Aí nós podemos
pensar que nós estamos olhando o cubo de
baixo.
Eu aqui eu vejo que isso aqui é a base
do cubo, mas eu tô olhando de cima e
vendo a base embaixo de mim. Mas eu
posso olhar como se eu tivesse olhando
assim, ó. Aqui tá a aresta de cima. Aqui
eu tô olhando a caixa por baixo.
Então aqui é a parte de baixo da caixa.
E aqui é é um tipo de loucura aqui.
É, mas seja como for, a gente vê o cubo.
Então quando a gente vê um cubo,
pessoal, isto a gente dá um testado.
Loucura. Carimba, pode recolher a
pessoa.
É. Não, mas é são guarda-chuva. É, é, é,
é. Então, aqui é só para reconhecer que
a mente vê
ah
através de um processo de construção,
que é não dual. A gente vê o cubo, mas
se a gente tivesse, por exemplo, uma
foto aqui também, tá cheio de pixel, a
gente olha, vê uma paisagem, ver coisa,
mas não tem aquilo ali, só tem pixel.
pegar um um uma lupa, não vai encontrar
senão isso, né?
Esse é o ponto. E então
a gente precisaria entender que os olhos
constróem, porque a gente não chega a
pensar, a gente não pensa que é um cubo,
a gente olha e vê e assim as várias
coisas. A gente olha uma fotografia, vê
o filho, a gente vê, a gente não tá
construindo, a gente não pensa que tá
pensando. Também a gente bota uma
gravação, escuta uma voz, aí tu entende
o que que aquela voz tá dizendo e tu até
pode imaginar que tem uma pessoa ali,
como num filme, né? a pessoa falou isso,
ela disse isso, mas não tem nem a pessoa
da visão e nem a pessoa do som, mas eu
vejo e ouço e entendo.
Então esse esse processo ele nos permite
entender que os ouvidos constróem a
realidade. Então a gente chama isso
consciência. Então, consciência de
olhos, consciência de ouvidos,
consciência de olfato,
paladar e
tato.
Sendo que tato, pessoal, é a base da
medicina tibetana.
Vou deixar assim, eu sou um flash porque
nós já estamos nos despedindo porque eu,
por exemplo, vocês param pouquinho, você
não tem uma sensação interna do corpo.
>> É, isso também tá dentro do tato. Toda a
sensação interna do corpo, ela é
delusiva.
Eu posso fazer a energia subida assim,
eu posso fazer várias experiências
internas simplesmente deslocando a
posição da minha mente. Isso tá ligado
ao tato. Só que o corpo inteiro ele
funciona de modo delusivo. Então, de
como eu imagino, como eu produzo, o
corpo tem efeitos.
A gente pensa que o corpo é matéria, é
densidade, mas não é. Ele é sustentado
pela energia. Energia é comandada pela
visualização da mente.
Se a gente pensar que nós vamos pedir
uma pizza, daqui a pouco vai vir uma
linda pizza francesa, que é melhor que a
italiana. Claro, né?
assim, é como criar confusão, né? Essa é
a ideia, assim.
E aí a gente já pensou, ops, que que eu
pediria então? Aí nós já estamos presos
pelas ideias ou de repente a gente,
uau, e depois do retiro a gente pode
tomar uma guerra.
Eu não sei agora assim, né, se pode ou
não pode, né?
Então surge essa, a gente se vê
armadilhado pela ideia e a gente de
repente o nosso corpo começa a reagir. A
gente quer isso, que aquilo, não, eu
acho que se não vier uma pizza, eu
deserto, não sou mais budista. Coisa,
né? Aí começa a surgir alguma coisa
assim. Então a gente vê que o corpo ele
fala,
ele fala, mas o que ele fala não é que
seja
sólido, a gente pode também trocar isso
completamente.
Também as pessoas, por exemplo, que se
vem se vem ord, na verdade ela esqueleto
e elas se olv espelho, elas
>> viu que a pessoa se vê gorda,
>> viu Elô?
experiência
e aí eu se tiver alguém chattando
foi muito tempo
que eu acho que é o caso
está dizendo que 1965
um documento que se chama
et que a Igreja Católica não rejeita o
que
as traduções e foi muito
ponto de vista da fé cristã a plenitude
da diz a salvação está apenas em Cristo.
Isso foi 75,
75.
E foi antes do Paulo.
>> João 23.
Pois é,
mas aí aí como é que os budistas vão
contra-atac? Eles vão dizer: "Não, isso
é uma incompreensão."
Por quê? Porque Jesus Cristo era uma
emanação do Buda. Então, a tradição
cristã inteira é uma manifestação
budista entende?
Esse é o problema. Então, quer dizer, o
problema não, isso é a verdade. Então,
Jesus Cristo, tendo um Buda, a tradição
cristã é uma das variantes do budismo.
Mas deixa eles lá pensando que eles são
budos, porque tudo, cada um tem que
pensar que é tudo.
Então, eu acho que o budismo vai
contra-atacar mais adiante
e vai gerar um cristianismo budista
assim. Aguardem,
né Fábio né?
Então aí surge o quê? As cinco
consciências, pessoal, de olhos,
ouvidos, nariz, língua e tato, elas são
vivas,
elas produzem as experiências que
aparecem na frente e a sexta pensa,
então elas estão todas juntas. Então,
nirmakaia,
Nirmanakia, que é o boda andando no
mundo, é isso.
Então, tem três corpos do Bodanir,
manakaia,
Sambogakia e Darmakaia. Darmacaia é
grande abertura, o silêncio não
construído.
E esses três não se separam, então eles
são o quarto corpo.
Tem quatro corpos. Então esse é o ponto
que o Buda vai atingir, né? Ele vai
purificar totalmente as experiências
comuns.
Então a gente vai se despedir, pessoal.
Era isso.
Que os méritos desse encontro se
expandam e toquem a todos. O mestre
universal da paz e da compaixão. Sua
Santidade da Leirama, juntamente com
todos os mestres e todas as tradições
que veiculam essa mensagem, tenham longa
vida. Que todos estejam a salvo de gerar
pensamentos negativos,
que esses pensamentos nunca surgem nossa
mente e que todos os seres também
estejam livres de pensamentos negativos.
ao longo de minhas muitas vidas e até
este momento,
alcançado, inclusive os méritos gerados
por esta prática e todas as que vier a
conseguir ofereço para o bem-estar dos
seres sencientes.
a doença, guerra, fome e sofrimento
diminuir para todos os seres, enquanto
sua sabedoria e compaixão aumentam nessa
em vidas futuras. Possa eu claramente
perceber todas as experiências como
sendo tão insubstanciais quanto do sonho
durante a noite e imediatamente
despertar para perceber a manifestação
de sabedoria pura não surgível de cada
fenômeno.
possa eu rapidamente alcançar a
iluminação
para trabalhar cestar pela liberação de
todos os budas e bodisatas em conjunto.
Seja qual for a sua motivação, tuação
benáfica de preces auspiciosas,
seja qual for a sua neficiência,
realizações e poderes benévolos. E seja
qual for a sua imensa sabedoria,
eu que igualmente venho
rogo para que possa alcançar as mesmas
qualidades. Neste exato momento, possam
nem mesmo os nomes doença, fome, guerra
e sofrimento ser ouvidos pelas pessoas e
nações da terra. Mas possam sim conduta
moral, mérito, riqueza e prosperidade
crescer e possam a suprema
bemaventurança e bem-estar
do dia
[Música]
de
salud
[Música]
São Paulo.
King
zin
[Música]
Então,
Bem-vindas. Obrigada. Obrigada.
Tirar foto.
>> Certeza,
pessoal. Beijo aí. Tudo de bom. Beijo.
Citinha.
>> Tchau, Lama. Obrigada.
>> Beijo.
>> Até mais tarde, né? Até mais tarde.
>> Até mais tarde.
>> Tchau. Obrigada.